un ex-président pour mobiliser les
électeurs démocrates barack obama était
en meeting hier soir en pennsylvanie
l'ultime débat entre les deux candidats
a lieu ce soir à nashville dans le
tennessee
mais depuis dimanche joe biden n'a fait
aucune sortie publique officiellement
pour préparer ce rendez vous crucial
c'est donc à l'ancien président
démocrate de rassembler les électeurs et
de les appeler à se rendre aux urnes
philadelphie
je vous demande de vous souvenir de ce
que ce pays peut être ce que ça fait
d'être traités avec respect et dignité
ce que c'est que lorsque nos élus se
comporte de manière responsable
je vous demande de croire en la capacité
de joey de kamala à sortir ce pays de
ces temps sombres et à nous aider à le
reconstruire car nous ne pouvons pas
abandonner ceux qui souffrent en ce
moment nous ne pouvons pas abandonner
les enfants qui ne reçoivent pas
l'éducation dont ils ont besoin pour le
moment nous ne pouvons pas abandonner
les manifestants qui nous ont inspirés
nous devons transformer leur
militantisme en action je ne pouvons pas
simplement imaginer un meilleur avenir
nous devons nous battre pour cela donald
trump lui était si fière en caroline du
nord pour mobiliser ses partisans
l'attitude du candidat républicain
contraste fortement avec celle de son
adversaire
il multiplie les meetings et ne cesse
d'attaquer biden si vous voulez que vos
enfants grandissent dans une nation
libre où ils peuvent s'exprimer
pratiquer leur religion et vivre selon
leurs convictions
alors vous devez vaincre joe biden
l'endormi et la gauche radicale
[Musique]
rejeter le fascisme de gauche voter pour
la liberté américaine votée pour
l'amérique d'abord voté pour rendre sa
grandeur à l'amérique
trump hebeisen ne se sont pas retrouvés
en face à face depuis le 29 septembre
pour éviter la cacophonie ce soir les
micros de l'ain seront coupés quand
l'autre prendra la parole
outre ce débat de la dernière chance
notamment pour trump à la traîne dans
les sondages
un autre enjeu se profile ce jeudi le
vote par les membres de la commission du
sénat pour confirmer la nomination des
micros ni barrette à la cour suprême la
juge traditionalistes a été choisi par
trump pour remplacer la progressiste
féministe ruth bader ginsburg morte en
septembre dernier une désignation qui
serait un coup dur pour les démocrates
et ferait basculer pour longtemps
l'institution dans le camp républicain